you know what's so funny that you
mentioned
um uh the
Edinburgh Castle stop so I think I did
this video right so obviously there's um
there's been a bunch of uh sponsors
there's a few of them that are on
YouTube a lot you see them all the time
it's like you can become a Lord oh yeah
yeah I'm not gonna name this because I
want to get in trouble yeah and there's
actually a ton of websites that do this
you know they're like hey if you if you
buy a thing for 60 bucks you get a one
foot plot of land and you're now a lord
right and so I was like I was like that
doesn't sound right
it's like my British sense
but it doesn't quite sound right so I
wanted to do this video I was like I
actually want to become like get a title
right so I started looking into it more
about how how one goes about it right
and it was interesting because I
you know tldr
um the way that the laws work in
Scotland is that you you can't transfer
one square of a one square foot of a
land to someone that's not that's too
small and you can't even even if they
they say they do you don't actually own
that land it's it's a dedicated souvenir
plot so you know they're kind of saying
hey yeah you own this land in our heads
in our database but like legally whoever
bought that land still owns it because
you can't you can't transfer land like
that it has to be transferred wholly
yeah um also they change the laws on how
titles work so yeah in Scotland you can
you can actually still get titles but I
believe it's only like um Baron so you
can become like you can be like a baron
of uh high water or something yeah
that's it depends on the name of the
place and stuff you can actually get
those titles because those are titles
that have existed before and so they
changed the rules where you can't it
used to be where the the title would
transfer with the ownership of the land
right but now that that's not how it
works so you can't transfer the title
with the land you can only buy the title
off of someone else and then there's no
guarantee that you can actually get it
recognized even if you buy it off
someone it's really weird
um I'm not 100 on all the legal legality
of it it seemed extremely complicated
and if you actually want to get one of
these titles
um there's a few ways you can do it you
can actually buy a title but it would it
would be somewhere in the range of 100
Grand yeah that sounds about right which
would make sense because they're very
limited right and people want these like
Rich [ __ ] want to be like the
baron of slogwart yeah
um
and there's another whole thing where
you you can actually get a title if you
own a historical piece of land in
Scotland yeah and then you have to
submit it but then also even if you own
this land you still need to be of it was
something along the lines of you need to
be of someone of notable stature and of
of good standing and Merit yeah you
can't just be some random dude buy a
plot of land and submit it you know
verified on Twitter you need to be
verified and have a Twitter blue
so this whole system is like extremely
complex and they don't even I'm pretty
sure from my knowledge they don't even
give out Lord titles anymore that's not
like a the only way to get a lord title
is to be born into it right this so
there's very few there's less and less
yeah so I think from my understanding
and again I didn't look too much into
that part but yeah it's literally I
think generational has to be gifted to
you by the Yeah round but they used to
sell them back in 1920. which is
actually when they used to trade hands
the most and then they stopped that so
you can't do that anymore right so
pretty much the yeah there's pretty much
no real hey you can definitely get one
it's very very I again I'm not an expert
this is like two hours of research you
pretty much cannot get one I'm just
gonna say like that you you can get it
very very very very very very difficult
you can get it but
999.97 people cannot get it right so
ultimately I just thought about this
thing and I was like damn this thing
suck you pay like 80 bucks just to have
somebody write oh Lord God you are you
are a Lord you are a Lord
you are and they I mean if you look at
all the fine print and all these
websites they do say it but the
marketing for a lot of these stuff and
the way they get like a lot of
influences and all the stuff to push it
is they're not like that they say yeah
you get to you get a one square plot
like no you don't yeah you do not you
cannot go to the land registry and say
hey I own this one square foot plot of
land in Scotland isn't that also similar
to the services where it's like you can
buy one square foot of the Moon as well
yeah that's [ __ ] that's like the
Moon the Moon in space counts as like
international waters right yeah
right now so you know it's just like I
don't know I just thought about it I'm
like I don't get why people stop
promoting it we're like obviously it
wouldn't make sense obviously you can't
be a lord
obviously this is not how it works well
we we know this because we I guess we
grew up in like the UK right so it's
just like something sounds sucks because
there aren't that many lords in the UK
yeah but yeah yeah and I guess also you
could argue well no comments for the
novelty it's for the fun of it it's like
what just spend five minutes and make a
stupid certificate
that whole thing is like it's a great
gift give to someone that's yeah well I
mean I don't know about that like I said
really yeah you know a lot of them they
maybe have some claims like and I'm not
trying to call them out I just think
that I just don't get why this is a
thing I just don't understand how it's
big yeah because I see quite a lot every
YouTuber promotes it and I'm like this
what the [ __ ] this is garbage again I'm
not naming names don't get in trouble
um there's a lot of them some of them
are like oh well they want to offset it
right so Chris isn't there well we plot
a tree and it's okay fine maybe you do
and it's like I I don't there's no way
to verify yeah I I don't know if you do
yeah you know even then quite the you
come into the question of like oh I
don't know I don't know how valid is
that is that really helpful is that like
I could just go and plan a [ __ ] trip
yeah
what if you are supplant it yourself I
may let you do it yeah like pull them
out being like okay I own this lad you
can't defy me by the way I'm alone let's
not get into carbon offsetting that's a
whole bag of water a can of worms that
we're not even gonna get into because
that's a whole other thing that is
questionable at best but yeah I just I
just for me it's like every now and then
some sponsors like this come around on
YouTube where everyone seems to be
promoting them and it's like
is anything wrong with it they're not
doing anything wrong I'm just saying
like I'm like fine I just don't get it
to me I'm like what is this no I get it
I get it especially it's hard especially
if it's like a new product that you just
you because this is like a something
like this is a very weird product right
and sometimes sometimes weird products
some of them can be legit but some of
them just don't make sense at all it's
yeah it's it's weird it's a gray area we
I don't [ __ ] know we try to like take
on as much small ships that I'm not
trying to get sued by the way
I'm just saying I I think it's not very
good yeah I mean that's why uh we don't
promote them yeah I think yeah and I
feel it's like especially like the
pressure is on for creators as well when
they see other like maybe notable
creators or like the shiromatics and
they're like well if they're getting
sponsored by this many creators must be
legit we're not above taking stuff that
is backfired on us right we've taken
stuff that we've maybe not liked in the
past right I think every YouTuber every
Creator learns the hard way of course
yeah you know I just it's not that I'm I
would never give a single credit [ __ ]
for promoting it because I just think
that's the game
um I just I'm just shocked at how
widespread it is right and I'm like this
seems like such a niche thing that is so
obviously not true I'm like I just don't
understand I I it blows my mind I don't
know yeah again I'm not trying to call
anyone out I know any YouTubers have
promote them bro I don't give a [ __ ]
it's yeah it's part of the game I'm just
yeah